[Música]
ese soy yo a ver
y
a
he estado trabajando con recursos
estás entrenando los contratando o
incluso despidiendo personas
y personas
eso
siempre
[Música]
y mi misión era despedir a tres cuartas
partes
y ahora
entonces cuando tú haces es muy sencillo
en cuanto te
a todas aquellas personas no gratas
porque no aportan tanto a la empresa y
empieza
si empiezas a tomar más cuando llegas a
ese grupo de personas que si son
productivas y que se aportan algo a la
empresa
i
esta persona
es responsable es cumplida no falta
entonces que tengo
y este increíble
es lo único bueno empieza a funcionar
ese reporte contiene
y pasó lo mismo para sordos
y empezamos a deshacer
es muy valiosa que realmente deben
pero
cuando esas personas
utilizamos el criterio de los valores
nos empezamos a aplicar
sin darnos cuenta cuáles eran las
personas que tenían más valores y
aportar
[Música]
ya no
en el valor
[Música]
del
de la parte triste
[Música]
no me interesa
la fortuna de entrevistarte
la gente
me ha pasado
bien
y le preguntó a los candidatos en los
tres valores
[Música]
es práctica
importantes y como prácticas
y nuevas pero la mayoría no
los valores son todos
responsabilidad y respeto
y varían mucho para decirle cómo llevar
el día a día
entonces esto es un poco
preguntas
y les digo que no
convencionalmente comas el día aquí a tu
casa
y
[Música]
sus canciones
por qué
sobre valores no que lo sepan decir
por acción
y un poco
y entendí vamos
las personas
la investigación
[Música]
en las gracias de civismo se le dijo
un poco en las primarias a las clases de
matemáticas y naturales español
y ya que no seamos verdad
en esa misma época los años 70
en países como españa en francia
las materias sobre derechos humanos y
ética
y no fue hasta los años 90 hasta 1993
cuando se volvió regresaron a las clases
de méxico las materias como formaciones
un espacio de 20 años
y muchos otros más
no sé si puede ser una incluye
pero los valores
y estoy de acuerdo
de la escuela
[Música]
una vez
volviendo a las gentes
[Música]
las entrevistas
me di cuenta
que los valores pueden ser determinantes
1 pacto es nadie
a todos para todos
y cuando uno como maestro
[Música]
un grupo y tiene la oportunidad
con el programa total de clases
40 horas
bien
de información
en menos de dos días
los esperamos de nuestros alumnos los
niños estas informaciones
y la ética
en las aulas
los de las casas
muchos dicen para la educación
[Música]
y
también rastros niños ahora son niños
un futuro a nacer
[Música]
explicando la importancia de cómo puede
ser
en el spa
y él y el escoger una persona
horas al día
y si quieres
[Música]
no es así
en fin
y un resultado en
ya sé
dijo
directamente
desde
cuáles son esos tres valores que tú
consideras importantes en el día
y como los médicos
[Aplausos]